The,
the brand idea is that the brand is
going to sum up all of your experience
with the product.
So it's not just the logo,
but the logo is part of it.
Um,
I think it might be be helpful for me to
back up and say,
you know,
the way I look at habits forming,
there's this concept of what I say
contacts q training,
reinforcement.
So the context is that within a specific
environment,
this is how I'm doing a particular thing
and that context is really important.
So,
you know,
if you think about the context of music,
so in the morning you may wake up to um,
you know,
a radio playing music,
your local radio station,
you may then go to an Ipod,
you know,
uh,
in your head when you go for your run in
the morning,
you get in a car,
you may listen to satellite radio,
you may listen to,
you know,
again,
you may listen to talk radio on the way
and you may listen to traffic.
Each of those things.
It's about music,
but the context changes how you're going
to access it.
And so this is the thing that within a
context you want to be able to help your
customers simplify their decisions and
it's all about making good,
simple decisions.
So for a brand to serve that role,
then you have to really identify how the
brand allows you to automate a decision.
How,
if I just,
you know,
okay,
I'm going to buy,
you know,
Campbell soup to have in the,
in my pantry,
because there are times when you know
that's going to solve that problem.
I'm wondering fix lunch for the kids.
I don't want to just fix them a cold
sandwich.
Hey,
hot soup.
So I feel like I'm a good parent because
I mean,
so there may be a lot of complexity,
there might be a lot of stuff involved
in it,
but it all gets summarized and that
Campbell's brand and that color and
everything else.
And that's why it can be so powerful.
And so for a brand you know,
that you knew,
you can see why,
what the challenges because there's no
history there.
So you've got a lot of work to do and
you're advertising and in and getting
people aware and then getting people to
understand when they should use you.
Um,
you think about how many websites there
are,
you think about how many news sources
there are.
I mean,
how do I get somebody to come to my
website?
And the key here is I've got to make a
behavior.
I've got to do something repeatedly
before my brain can kind of lay down the
tracks that automate that process.
And it's that idea of focusing on
behavior versus attitude,
which is so fundamental in terms of our
understanding of how the brain works.
So we're before advertisers and
marketers were really,
really focused on trying to get you to
have a particular belief or a particular
attitude.
What my contention is,
it's much more important that I get to
behavior because when you talk about the
idea that customer satisfaction doesn't
predict behavior,
well,
85 percent of people who leave a one
product for another report being
satisfied with the ones that are
leaving.
So,
you know,
if I'm satisfying them,
then why do I measure it?
Why do I care?
And it seems kind of unfair.
Wait a second.
I did a great job.
I satisfied them.
Why aren't they staying?
But the reality is that that for
customers that,
you know,
satisfaction doesn't really isn't,
is a conscious concept and a lot of our
decision making is unconscious.
So a great example of this is the way
people watch television now.
We used to get TV guide.
Yeah.
We used to like plan out what we're
going to watch and then plan our time to
be in front of a television and now what
a lot of people do.
I mean,
and the numbers are really staggering.
It's really surprising is they,
is they have no idea what they're going
to watch.
They sit down,
they pick up the remote and the remote
now has these digital guides and they
flip through and they look what's on and
so it's a total different.
Now,
at no point did someone go,
well,
consciously I've decided that I no
longer want to orient myself around the
television schedule.
When I get in front of the TV,
I'll look to see what's on the point
here is that's the way we learn a large
part of is this unconscious learning
that we do from these complex feedback
mechanisms that we get from the
environment,
and so often companies fail miserably to
really understand how people are making
these decisions.